dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here through
over 200 episodes of this series we
talked about many learning based
algorithms that are able to solve
problems that previously seemed
completely impossible they can look at
an image and describe what they depict
in a sentence or even turn video game
graphics into reality and back amazing
new results keep appearing every single
week however an important thing that we
need to solve is that if we deploy these
neural networks in a production
environment we would want to know if we
are relying on a good or bad a Oz
decision the narrative is very simple if
we don't trust the classifier we won't
use it and perhaps the best way of
earning the trust of a human would be if
the AI could explain how it came to a
given decision strictly speaking a
neural network can explain it to us but
it will show us hundreds of thousands of
neuron activations that are completely
unusable for any sort of intuitive
reasoning so what is even more difficult
to solve is that this explanation
happens in a way that we can interpret
an earlier approach use decision trees
that described what the learner looks at
and how it uses this information to
arrive to a conclusion this new work is
quite different for instance imagine
that a neural network would look at all
the information we know about a patient
and tell us that this patient likely has
the flu and in the meantime it could
tell us that the fact that the patient
has a headache and sneezes a lot
contributed to the conclusion that he
has the flu but the lack of fatigue is
notable evidence against it our doctor
could take this information and instead
of blindly relying on the output could
make a more informed decision a fine
example of a case where AI does not
replace but augment human labor an
elegant tool for a more civilized age
here we see an example image where the
classifier explains which region
contributes to the decision that this
image depicts a cat and which region
seems to be counter evidence we can use
this and not only for tabulated patient
data and images but text as well in this
other example we try to find out whether
a piece of written text is about
Christianity or atheism note
the decision itself is not as simple as
looking for a few keywords even a mid
tier classifier is much more
sophisticated than that but it can tell
us about the main contributing factors a
big additional selling point is that
this technique is model agnostic which
means that it can be applied to other
learning algorithms that are able to
perform classification it is also a
possibility that an AI is only right by
chance and if this is the case we should
definitely know about that and here in
this example with the additional
explanation it is rather easy to find
that we have the bad model that looks at
the background of the image and thinks
that it is the fur of a wolf the tests
indicate that humans make significantly
better decisions when they lean on
explanations that are extracted by this
technique the source code of this
project is also available thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time
[Music]